president biden chose to highlight the
nation's lower unemployment rate on
friday the late the latest labor
department report found the number of
jobless fell from 4.6 in october to 4.2
in november the lowest it's been since
the start of the pandemic but job growth
was weaker than expected the economy
adding just 210 000 jobs christina
raffini has the details from the white
house christina good morning
good morning dana well the jobs report
wasn't all bad but it wasn't as good as
had been predicted and that alone was
enough to spook investors who were
already worried about a labor shortage
supply chain issues and that new covet
variant
our jobs recovery is going very strong
nursing what he told reporters was a
cold from his grandson president biden
tried to focus on the healthier parts of
the u.s economy we're looking at the
sharpest one-year decline in
unemployment ever according to the
latest jobs report unemployment ticked
down to 4.2 percent but the economy only
added 210 000 jobs
half a million fewer than economists had
predicted i also know that despite this
progress families are anxious they're
anxious about covert they're anxious
about the cost of living the economy
more broadly
that anxiety extends to wall street
where stocks slid on friday following a
rough week of trading
and also to the hospitality sector which
added 23 000 jobs last month but is
still down 1.3 million pre-pandemic
positions hopefully it ends sooner
rather than later
because it is tiring and it's tough to
come in every day knowing that you can
be running short but amid the economic
stress a bit of bipartisan relief from
of all places congress the motion is
adopted where lawmakers reached an
agreement late thursday night on a stop
gap measure to avoid a shutdown
and fund the government through
mid-february funding the government
isn't a great achievement
there's a bare minimum of what we need
to get done but
in these times a bipartisan cooperation
is worth recognition
now president biden signed that funding
measure that'll keep the government open
but there's much more on the
congressional to-do list including a
debt ceiling measure and the buildback
better plan which the president would
really like to see under his christmas
tree michelle no vacation in sight for
him at least not for the next few weeks
christina thank you